[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء
مع نهايه الجوله الاولى من دوري المجموعات
في كاس العالم كبار اسيا يحرجون المرشحين
للفوز بالبطوله
روسيا
العربيه على المثلث الحدود بين بولندا
واوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا توترا وتعزيزات لحرس
الحدود
لمليشياتها في المنطقه فتم اعتقاله انه
لاعب الكره الشهير يوير يخوري
المخلب السيف التركيه تمتد لمناطق بعمق
الشمال سوري للمره الاولى ومساع امريكيه
للتهديئه
[موسيقى]
في كاس العالم فازت البرتغال على غانا
بصعوبه اثنين ثلاثه قبل قليل وقبلها انتزع
المنتخب الكوري الجنوبي نقطه ثمينه من
الارجواي بعد تعادل سلبي ضمن مباريات
المجموعه الثامنه بكاس العالم في قطر
وشهدت الجوله الاولى اداء قويا للمنتخبات
الاسيويه امام منتخبات كبرى مرشحه للفوز
بكاس العالم وحصلت عليه سابقا اولى
المفاجات كانت بفوز السعوديه مستحقا امام
الارجنتين بنتيجه 2-1 فيما وصلت اليابان
الاداء القوي لمنتخبات اسيا بهزيمه قاسيه
للماكينات الالمانيه بالنتيجه ذاتها ثم
اختمت كوريا الجنوبيه الجوله الاولى
للمنتخبات الاسيويه بتعادل مهم امام
الاوروجواي تبدا غدا الجوله الثانيه اذا
في دور المجموعات في كاس العالم بلقاء يضم
قطر والسنغال
استعانه لاعبوا المنتخب الارجنتيني بافراد
عائلاتهم لرفع معنوياتهم بعد الهزيمه امام
المنتخب السعودي في افتتاح مباريات
المنتخب بين في مونديال قطر 20 22 ففي مقر
اقامه المنتخب الارجنتيني في الدوحه التقى
القائد ليونيل ميسي بزوجته انتونيلا
واطفاله الثلاثه وماتوا وكذلك اجتمع بقيه
اللاعبين مع اسرهم وسط اجواء عاطفيه
وايجابيه قبل المباراه الثانيه امام
المكسيك يوم السبت في السادسه ومن اجل ذلك
قرارات كالوني تاجيل تمارين الارجنتين من
مسائي امس الاربعاء الى صباح اليوم الخميس
وتتصدر السعوديه المجموعه الثالثه بثلاث
نقاط مقابل نقطه واحده للمكسيك وبولندا
فيما تتزيل الارجنتين الترتيب
[موسيقى]
ومن الدوحه ينضم الينا مفيد العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي اهلا بك عبد المحسن يعني
انت تتواجد في منطقه المشجعين وانتهت منذ
قليل المباراه التي فازت بها البرتغال
انقل لنا الاجواء من عندك
نعم راويه بالفعل كانت اجواء مجنونه في
هذه اللحظه الى اخر همم الدقائق اواخر حتى
الثواني عندما كاد ان يفقد كريستيانو
توازنه وهو في خارج دبكه او في خارج خرج
من الملعب بعد استبداله الا ان هناك خطا
في اللحظات الاخيره من حارس مرمى البرتغال
كاد ان ياتي التعادل لمنتخب غانا في
الحقيقه اه اه
المنطقه
في هدف الاول في هذه المباراه المباراه
كانت قويه جدا
وكانت غزيره في الاهداف في هذه اللحظات
التي كانت تستخدم المباراه اخرى وهي اخر
مباراه مباريات الجوله للمنتخب البرازيلي
ضد المنتخب همم هذه المباراه الاخيره
سيكون في المنتخب البرازيلي في ظهوره
الاول في قطر وهو يعول عليه كثيرين بان
تحديدا البرازيليين ومحبه المنتخب
البرازيلي بان يعوده مجددا بكاس العالم
واخر كاس عالم كانت قد فازت في البرازيل
هي في عام
2002 في اليابان وسوريا الجنوبيه في في
هذه اللحظات الراويه
[موسيقى]
المحيطه
بهذه المنطقه بعد نهايه همم المباراه
مباراه المنتخب البرتغالي الى المشجعين
المنتخب البرتغالي يغادرون
[تصفيق]
بعد
انتهت هذه المباراه بفوز منتخب
البرتغال وايضا هنالك يوم مشجعين منتخب
البرازيلي يستعيدونها
لمباراه اخرى مباراه
البرازيل ضد تركيا
عبد المحسن يعني صوتك غير واضح ولكن اود
ان اسالك بانه اليوم انتهت المباريات
الاولى لكل المجموعات همم لخص لنا ابرز
المفاجاه وابرز الاسامي التي برزت في هذا
الدور
في الحقيقه راويه كان هنالك تحديات كبيره
في هذه الجو الاولى انتهت بمفاجات لم يكن
احد يتوقعها بدا المنتخب السعودي بالفوز
على المنتخب
بهدفين مقابل هدف واحد من تم تتالت
المفاجاه بعد انتصار المنتخب الياباني ومن
ثم اليوم تعادل المنتخب الكوري الجنوب اذا
هنالك مفاجات كبرى حدثت في هذه الجوله
ايضا بعض
المنتخبات التي همم كانت قد توجه رساله
بشكل كبير من المنتخبات الاقل حبا دائما
في هذه البطوله فبالتالي بدات في الخوف من
ان يكون مصيرها كمصير مباراه المنتخب
الارجنتين والسعوديه او حتى اليابان ضد
همم
الجوله القادمه ايضا ستكون هناك مباريات
قويه
او متوقع ان يكون هناك تركيز اكبر على
المنتخبات التي حققت الفوز في الجوله
الاولى ومتوقع ايضا ان يكون الضغط اكبر
على المنتخبات التي همم حققت المفاجات
راويه تحدث تحديدا عن المنتخب السعودي
والمنتخب
الياباني اللذان فازت بالتالي في سيكون
الضغط
الماضيه
من الدوحه عبد المحسن الحربي
هذا واصبح نجم منتخب البرتغال كريستيانو
رونالدو ولا اللاعب يسجل في خمس بطولات
متتاليه لكاس العالم بعد تسجيله هدفا من
ركله جزاء بمرمى منتخب غانا خلال افتتاح
مباريات المنتخب
كما يستهدف كريستيانو رونالدو تحطيمه رقم
قياسيه عمره 56 عاما بيسعى الى تسجيل
ثلاثه اهداف على الاقل بالنسخه الحاليه
ليرفع رصيده الى 10 اهداف موندياليه ويحطم
رقم الاسطوره البرتغاليه صاحب تسعه اهداف
في المونديال وبالتالي سيصبح رونالدو افضل
هداف للبرتغال في نهايته كاس العالم
كاد ان يعتزل قبل 18 شهرا لكنه وجد نفسه
وجد نفسه الحارس الاساسي في منزلي قطر هذه
قصه حارس منتخب هولندا وهي من قصص
المونديال الكثيره منها مفاجاه ومنها
غريبه واخرى مؤلمه فراحله الحارس اندريس
صاحب ال 28 عاما نحو قطر كانت مذهله فعلا
وكادت هذه المسيره ان تنتهي لولا اسرار
على المواصله في سبيل تحقيق حلمه في كره
القدم وفي تفاصيل القصه انه قبل ثلاث
سنوات كان روبرت حارسا احتياطيا في فريقيا
في القسم الثالث الايطالي حيث ارتكب
الكثير من الاخطاء التي جعلته لا يظهر الا
نادرا ليجد نفسه في نهايه عام 2019 بدون
نادم لكنه وقع مع نادي دور درفت القابع في
الدرجه الهولنديه في عام 2010 الا انه
عاده وفسخ عقده بعد خمسه اشهر فقط بسبب
سوء المستوى الذي قدمه اندرياس نو بارتي
حراسه مرمى الفريق ثم توجه الى نادي جو
اهاد ايجلز وشارك معه في لقاء واحد طوال
موسم كروي كامل ما دفعه لترك النادي ليصبح
مره اخرى بدون فريق هنا زاد وضعه النفسي
سواء سوءا فعليا ودفعه التفكير في انهاء
مسيرته الكرويه والتفكير بوظيفه ضابط شرطه
لكن المفاجاه حصلت عندما اعطاه مدرب فريق
هيرن فين هل هولاندي فرصه وامن بقدرته حيث
كان حاضرا في 14 لقاءا وجنب فريقه الهبوط
للدرجه الثانيه هذا التالق الكبير جذب
انظار مدرب منتخب هولندا لويس فانغال الذي
استدعاه للمعسكر التحضري لمنتخب الطواحين
قبل بدء المونديال يبتسم له الحظ اخيرا
ويجد نفسه في نوفمبر من عام 2022 اساسيا
في نهائيات كاس العالم بقطر اذا هذا
اللاعب قدم اداء كبيرا ومبهرا امام
السنغال في اولى مباريات المنتخب الهولندي
في منزلقه قطر وغالبا سيبقى الرقم واحد في
شباك الطواحين بعد ادائه اللافت هذا
[موسيقى]
تشهد الحدود البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه مرحله
من التوتر الخطير تسحبها عمليات مراقبه
كبيره من قبل الطرفين هذا وتستمر كيا في
بناء جدار فاصل على طول الشريط الحدود
الفاصل بين اوكرانيا وبلاروسيا الخط
الفاصل بين الدولتين لم يعد اسلاك شائكه
بل قنبله موقوته على شفايفيجاره تعزيزات
لحرس الحدود البلار روسي يقابلها دعم
عسكري اوكراني في بعض الاحيان بالمعدات
الثقيله
مواقف استفزازيه مختلفه تحدث خلال الفتره
الاخيره على سبيل المثال دخل ذات مره في
فصل الصيف وعنصر اوكراني نحو الاراضي
البله روسيه وكان يمسك قنبله يدويه ويهدد
بتفجيرها واسعف حينها زملائه الامر وصحبه
في ظل ظروف الحاليه تقوم مين سكربيبا تو
موسكو برصد التغييرات المتقلبه حاله
استنفار للتدخل السريع لدى اي طريق محتمل
خاصه ان الاخيره تقوم بمراقبه الحدود بشكل
كامل بين البلدين عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من الحدود البيلاروسيه
الاوكرانيه
عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد يعني
انت تتواجد في هذه المدينه اللي هي مثل ما
ذكرنا على الحدود وقرب بزياره الجدار الذي
يتم بناء انقل لنا مشاهداتك من هناك
مساء الخير راويه نعم يعني هي المدينه
الاكثر حساسيه في الاراضي البيلاروسيه هي
تقع تجاور من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه
الاراضي البولنديه ومن الجهه الجنوبيه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه رويه تعود الجميع على
ان الشريط الحدود هو اسلاك شائكه ورموز
يعني تعني للدوله باشياء كثيره لكن لكي ان
تتخيلي ان الوضع اليوم هناك اشبه بالقنبله
الموقوطه كما ذكرت هي واقعه على فواتي
بركان استفزاز طبعا كثيره تبدا طبعا بدخول
بعض الجنود من الجانبين وصولا الى مرور
بعض المعدات الثقيله من الشريط الحدودي
لابد هنا من لفت الانتباه بان حرس الحدود
والاتفاقيه المعروفه لدى الجميع جوه
العالم يعني تكمن في وجود هؤلاء اللي يعني
الجنود والعناصر من حرس الحدود على الشريط
الحدودي لكن منلاحظه هو وجود عسكري من قبل
الطرفين وحراسه وكاميرات مراق واعمال
كبيره طبعا المنطقه على الشريطه الحدودي
هي خاويه بشكل كبير من السكان معظم النقاط
الحدوديه ومراكز العبور مغلقه بشكل كامل
باستثناء طبعا بعض المناطق التي تمر عبرها
البضائع التجاريه راويه طبعا ما يعيد
للاذهان قضيه جدار برلين سابقا الذي قسم
حينها العالم الى نصفين شاهدناه اليوم
كانت العربيه كان قد شاهدت قبل نحو نصف
سنه من الان الجدار العازل التي تبنيه
بولندا مع الاراضي الاوكرانيه واليوم
نلاحظ بان الجانب الاوكراني يقوم بمد جدار
لعشرات الكيلومترات على طوال الشريط
الحدود مع الاراضي البولاروسيا نلاحظ بان
هذا الجدار اصبح يقص اوروبا نوعا ما الى
نصفين طبعا همم من جهه هي بيلاروسيا
وروسيا ومجهه اخرى معظم وباقي الدول
الاوروبيه
بشكل كبير الشارع في هذه نعم تحدثت عن
استفزازات وخروقات تحصل احيانا كيف يتصرف
حرس الحدود مع كيف يتعامل معها من الطرفين
بطبيعه الحال
لنكون منصفين في هذا الامر تسلمنا اليوم
مقاطع فيديو من اجانب البيروسي يظهر
تسجيلات من نقاط الحدود طبعا الامر يعني
كبير جدا يبدا بعمليات استفزازات برفع
البندقيات نحو الجانب الاخر مرور مدرعه
ثقيله من تلك المناطق خروج بعض العناصر
على المناطق المجاوره لكن الجانبين ان كان
قلبي لا روسي او الاوكراني يسعون لجذب
يعني واحتواء هذا الاشكال بشكل كبير كي لا
تحدث مشكله كبيره كنا قد طرحنا سؤالا على
القائم على هذه النقطه الحدوديه اليوم
راويه وطلبناه بالحديث عن انه في حال دخل
احد الجنود او احد عناصر من يعني من الجهه
الاخرى نحو الاراضي هو يتحدث مباشره بان
رفاقه يقومون بسحبه لان الجانب الاخر مضطر
لاطلاق النار وتحيد وتصفيه
سلطه بين الجانبين
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
انقاذوا الطفل ازكى يرفع جرعه الامل
اندونيسيا تسابق الوقت للعطور على عشرات
المفقودين في زلزال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد تاييده للاحتجاجات
الشعبيه في ايران وانتقاده دعم بلاده
للمليشات التابعه لها في المنطقه السلطات
الايرانيه القبضه على اللاعب الايراني
الشهير والريفوري لينضاف بذلك الى قائمه
الرياضيين الذين سجلتهم ايران الى جانب
باقي المعتقلين من المعاردين
[موسيقى]
تنوع الطرق على احتجاجات في ايران
والتعبير عن الثقه في البلاد من تظاهرات
الاعتصامات مرورا بالاضرابات وكتابه
الشعارات على جدران على مؤسسات النظام
وصولا الى احتجاج الطلبه في المدارس
والجامعه ومؤخرا مطالبات جماعيه للاستقاله
من البرلمان الايراني للتضامن مع
المحتاجين ومناهضه القمع وقتلهم من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه الايرانيه ودعت مجموعه من
الكتاب في محافظه كردستان غرب البلاد في
بيان الى استقاله جماعيه للبرلمانيين
التضامنا مع الشعب الحزينه وفقا ما وصفه
البيان واعلن المواقعون على البيان دعمهم
للمطالب الشرعيه للمواطنين الايرانيين
المتجسده في الحريه والعداله والسلام
واذان قتل الناس في اي مكان
[تصفيق]
وبينما تتنوع وطرق الاحتجاج ينوع النظام
الايراني مشاهدينا هو الاخر من طرق قمعه
للمظاهرات سواء بقنسهم او خطفهم وتغيبهم
ومحاكمتهم ميدانيا حيله النظام الايراني
هذه المره كانت استخدام سيارات الاسعاف
لاعتقالي وخطف المحتاجين بعد التسلل الى
داخل الاحتجاجات واختراقها على اساس انها
طاقم طبي وفقا لنيويورك تايمز ويتبع عناصر
الامن اسلوبا تمويها عبر ارتداء زي
الممرضين والاطباء المسعفين ثم الدخول بين
المحتاجين على اساس انهم مؤيدين للتظاهرات
ومتطوعين لمساعده جرح الاحتجاجات ويؤكد
شهود عيان للصحيفه الامريكيه ان القوات
الام زجت ثلاثه متظاهرين في بدايه الشهر
الماضي الى الداخل سيارات الاسعاف بالقوه
بالرغم من ان المحتاجين الثلاثه لم يكونوا
مصابين ومن ثم تبين اختفائهم لتتحول ايران
الى سجن كبير مع تجاوز عدد المعتقلين اكثر
من 14,000 معتقل خلال الاحتجاجات المستمره
منذ مقتل مهس امين وفقا لارقام الامم
المتحده طبعا والتي اكدت مقتل 40 طفلا في
تلك الاحتجاجات حتى الان
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده التي طالبت السلطات
الايرانيه بوقف حمله القمع هذه دعت ايضا
الى الكشف عن مصير المعتقلين خصوصا من
صدرت بحقهم احكام الاعدام مشدده على ضروره
التراجع عن هذه الاحكام
ما يقولوش ناوي
في ايران وقوات الباسيج استخدمت الرصاصه
الحي والمطاطيه ضد المتظاهرين بالاضافه
لوسائل قمع اخرى وفقا لتقارير موثقه تقدر
حصيله الوفيات باكثر من 300 شخص حتى
اللحظه بينهم 40 طفلا على الاقل وهذا امر
غير مقبول تلقينا تقارير تفيد بان الجرح
في المظاهرات يخشون الذهاب الى المستشفيات
حتى لا يتم اعتقالهم التوام الطبيه تحدثت
عن تدخلات من قبل قوات الامن اثناء علاجهم
للجرحى مما تم جمعه من تقاريرها هناك نحو
14,000 شخص معتقلين لدى السلطات بما فيهم
اطفال
المانيا هي الاخرى جددت تمديدها بالقمع
المميته للاحتجاجات في ايران وطالبت بوقف
الحملات المنهجه بحق المتظاهرين وقالت
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان ايران رفضت مرارا
دخول البعثه من مجلس حقوق الانسان ورصد
الانتهاكات وكشفت عن مشروع قرار امم
لتشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله توفق الانتهاكات
زخريرا في الداخل ايضا ارتفعت نسبه مشاركه
الفنانين والرياضيين والمثقفين الايرانيين
المتضامنين مع الاحتجاجات في بلادهم حيث
نشر مجموعه من كتاب وفنانين واكاديميين ما
قال المشتركا يبدون فيه تعاطفهم مع
المحتاجين وهو امر زاد من غضب النظام
الايراني وفقا للموند الفرنسي
حكومات نظامي
[موسيقى]
وصوتهم يمكن ان يؤثر في الاحتجاجات
اهلا بك اااه بالفعل يعني دعينا بدايه
نعرف من هو بالرياض الغفور هو لاعب الان
في لاعب في فولاذ الاهواز سابقا كان يلعب
في فريق السودان طهران وايضا عضو في
الفريق الوطني الايراني هو كردي من
الاغذيه الدينيه السنيه في ايران يا غفوري
على على مدى الاحتجاجات ليس فقط في هذه
الاحتجاجات ايضا في احتجاجات 2019 هو كتب
وقف مع الناس ضد همم ضد الغمع الحكومه
ايضا في احتجاجات 2020 في الاهواز ايضا
وقف مع المحتجين العرب في الاهواز والان
ايضا كان هو من اوائل ال- ال- همم خلينا
نقول ال-
الرياضيين اللي بيوقف مع المحتجين وغرد
ونشر ونشر صوره
وطالب السلطات همم سماع المحتاجين وعدم
غسل همم المحتاجين حتى حتى شاهدنا في اخر
همم
تغريد له هو طالب ال الحكومه الايرانيه
بعدم قتل الاكراد فهو في هذا في هذا السبب
دفع الحكومه الايرانيه الا بدايه ان كانوا
يريدها ارادوا ان يعتقلوه في من قبل شهر
ايضا منعوا اعتقاله في
الكادر الفني لفريق فولات والان سمعنا خبر
احتقاله ايضا ان استمعنا الان ان الرئيس
فريق فلان قدمته احتجاجا
لاحتقال احد لعيبته فوري
هذه الاسماء سيد قصي التي ذكرتها كثيرا
ومتنوعه الامر الذي يمبا بدعم كبير وواسع
لم تشهده اا يعني الاحتجاجات السابقه التي
شهدتها ايران لماذا هذا الدعم الان لهذه
الاحتجاجات ما بماذا تفرق يعني
بعض اللعيبه وقفوا مع احتجاج ايضا في 2009
من خلال
الفريق الوطني كمثال علي كريمي ومهدي مهدي
بيك لكن الان لماذا انتشرت بشكل اوسع هذه
همم الوقف مع المحتاجين السبب الرئيسي هو
الشارع هم اللعيبه او الفنانين يقولوا
احنا ناخذ مشروعيتنا ومحبوبيتنا من الشارع
ويجب ان نكون صوت هذا الشهر الشارع الان
ينادي الحكومه همم محترض ومحتاج على على
الغوانين اللي موجوده في الحكومه في
النظام الايراني فلذلك هم يشوفونها
مسؤوليه اجتماعيه قبل ان تكون مسؤوليه
سياسيه على اعتقهم ان يبينوا وجد نظرهم
ويواصل الصوت هذا الشارع محتاج للمجتمعات
الدوليه لانهم لديهم صوت يمكن سماع اكثر
من الناس المحتاجه في الشارع فلذلك يودوا
ان يكون صوت الشارع داخل الايراني
شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن قصي الدورقي الباحث
في الشؤون الاجتماعيه والرياضيه
[موسيقى]
بعدها سلسله الغارات الجويه والضربات
المدفعيه على المناطق الكرديه في سوريا
وتهديد اردوغان باجتياح بري افاد مراسل
العربيه ان وفدا امريكيا يجري لقاء مع
قيادات كرديه في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في شمال شرق سوريا لبحث كيفيه وقف الهجمات
التركيه واوضح عمرو مراسلنا ان منسق مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي للشرق الاوسط ما
كورج هو ومن يقود جهود التهدئه بين انقره
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه فيما اتهمت
الاخيره تركيا بارتكاب جريمه حرب
باستهدافها البنيه التحتيه شمال سوريا
مؤسف
ومخزي موقف امريكا وموقف روسيا تاسف طبعا
روسيا معروف له علاقات روسي نطلب من تركيا
يطلب رجاء يعني الموقف لازم يساعدونا يعني
لما الامريكان يحتاجون نحنا عم نوقف معاون
والروز كمان وهلا الاجتياح التركي ما عم
لاقي لا روسيا ولا امريكا عم يساعدونا
بهالمجال وخصوصا انه يصير مثلا همم هجره
جماعيه هل العالم كلها لوين ت- تروح كل
الحدود مسكره بوجهنا يعني هجوم على سياره
مدنيه على الحزام بيني وبين مطار قام ب
200 متر الطائرات كشف وين الرادارات
والمراقبه اذا هناك تواضع روسي امريكي همم
في منطقه القامشلي
ليس القصف والاجتياح البري التركي وحده ما
يخشاه الاكراد في سوريا اذ ان هناك ما
يشغل بالهم اكثر وهو التقارب بين انقره
ونظام الاسد في سوريا وهو ما قد يعود سلبا
مستقبلا على اداره الذاتيه الكرديه شمال
شرق البلاد وهو ما تعارضه انقره بشده
وتعتبر وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه منظمه
ارهابيه مرتبطه بحزب العمال الكردستاني
لكن كيف تطورت العلاقات بين انقره والنظام
السوري التي شهدت مراحل دراماتيكيه كيف لا
واردوغان الذي كان يصف بشار الاسد بالمجرم
لا يستبعد اليوم اللقاء به لما يخدم الامن
القومي
ففي عام 2012 وما عندي لها الاحداث في
سوريا اغلق تركيا سفاراتها في دمشق
احتجاجا على قمع نظام الاسد للمتظاهرين
وقرر اردوغان اتهامه للاسد بالمجرم في ما
وصف الاخير نظيره التركي بدعم الارهاب
وبعدها قدمت ان دعما كبيرا للمعارضه
السوريه وتحولت اسطنبول الى مقر للائتلاف
الوطني لقوى الثوره والمعارضه السوريه قبل
ان تبدا دعم الفصائل المعارضه المسلحه
وتوالت بعدها الوعود التركيه على لسان
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بمحاسبه بشار
الاسد على ممارسته بحق المتظاهرين
والمعتقلين السوريين وتوعد باسقاط الاسد
عن الحكم مهما كالف الامر لكنه اردوغان
اليوم الذي لا يستبعد عوده المياه الى
مجارها الى بل حتى اللقاء والمصالحه مع
نظام البشري الاسد بقوله انه لا خلاف
ابديه في السياسه وان اللقاء مع الاسد قد
يحصل بعد الانتخابات التركيه في عام 2013
سوريا
[موسيقى]
لازمته
خالص
[موسيقى]
الاصيل
اعلنت وزاره السياحه السعوديه عن انتخاب
المملكه رئيسا للمجلس التنفيذي لمنظمه
السياحه العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده
وذلك خلال اجتماع الدوره ال 117 التي عقدت
بمراكش في المغرب لتصبح السعوديه اول دوله
خليجيه تشغل هذا المنصبه بدوره قال وزير
السياحه احمد الخطيب ان السعوديه تدعم
جهود المنظمه للترويجي للقطاع السياحيه
حيث تعهدت بانفاق 800 مليار دولار على شكل
استثمارات حكوميه في قطاع السياحه بحلول
عام 2030 واكد وزير السياحه السعوديه ان
المملكه ستواصل دعمها لجهود اعاده تصميم
القطعه السياحي بما يساعد على تعزيز النمو
المستدامه ومجابهه التحديات المستقبليه
بكفاء
[موسيقى]
تراجع مؤشر خطاب الكراهيه الى الثلث على
تويتر خلال الشهرين الماضيين وفقا ما
اعلنه الملياردير الماسك الذي هنا فريق
عمله على جهوده الكبيره بعد ان انخفضت
تغريدات الكراهيه من 10 ملايين الى
مليونين ونصف المليون ما بين شهري اكتوبر
ونوفمبر وفي وقت سابق كشف تقرير لمركز
لمكافحه الكراهيه الرقميه ان استخدام
الاهانات العنصريه على التويتر ارتفع
ثلاثه اضعاف مقارنه بالاعوام السابقه منذ
استحوذ الماسك على المنصه الرقميه واسعه
الانتشار
[موسيقى]
ما الذي سنخسره في حال فقد نا تويتر
سياسيه ليس فقط على الولايات المتحده ولكن
ايضا على العالم الديمقراطيه وفق ما تحدثت
عنه مجله فارم في الولايات المتحده على
سبيل المثال الحسابات الاخباريه على تويتر
تراجعوا حضورها واحتمال زوالها هذا الامر
يتحمل مسؤوليته بشكل مباشر مالك تويتر
الجديد
لكن لابد من الحداد على المشهد الجاري في
الشركه لانها كانت عاملا قويا لابراز
الطابعه الديمقراطيه على مدار الجيل
الماضي تقول المجله الامريكيه
قبل تويتر اي من في الثمانينات تحديدا
كانت الاخبار في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يهيمن عليها كليا عدد صغير من
الشركات بدءا بما يسمى الصحف الوطنيه مثل
نيويورك تايمز ودوستري جون للواو عشان
تبوسط وحصل معظم الامريكيين على اخبارهم
من ثلاث شبكات تلفزيونيه وطنيه مثل سي بي
اس وان بي سي واي بي سي بعد صعود وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل عام وتويتر بشكل
خاص تم تدمير نظام المعلومات القديمه
واصبحت المنصه منبر للجميع سواء افراد
عاديين او شركات كبرى واصبح بامكان الجميع
مواكبه ما يجري حول العالم سواء في
افريقيا او شمال شرق اسيا او دوائر
التاريخ الاكاديمي في الولايات المتحده
وغيرها من المجالات العلميه والطبيه
والثقافيه والفنيه بشكل موثوق والاهم من
ذلك جوده المعلومات التي يتم مشاركته
اعتمرت فريق باريس لان البدائل الجديده
تويتر ليست وعده ومن الصعب استبدال من
التقدمت للملايين نظاما نخبويا واستحواذ
ماسك على المنصه يهدد بتدمير هذا النظام
ودائما حسب فرن بولس
وانضم الينا من سان فرانسيسكو مراسل
العربيه حسين الطود اهلا بك حسين يعني بما
يخص موضوع تراجع مؤشر خطاب الكراهيه
الماسك يقول بانه تراجع اما تقرير لمركز
مكافحه الكراهيه الرقميه يقول يعني
الكراهيه والمصطلحات ما زالت موجوده على
المنصه ما حقيقه الموضوع بالعكس تقول بان
هذا زادت
تحيه لك راويه
التي قال فيها انه مؤشر الكريات تراجع هو
يرسل برساله تضمنه الى الجمعيات الحقيقيه
والنشطين الذي الذين يتهمونه بانه من خلال
همم
على العمليات التي يجيها الان التغيرات
التي يجريها سيزيد خطاب الكراهيه ولكن من
المرجع ان تزداد هذه المواجهه الان خاصه
بعد همم التصويت الذي انتهى منذ قليل حول
العفو العام الذي اقترحه الى الماس على
الحسابات المحظوره التي سيسمح لها الان
التصويت انتهى ب 72% مؤيدافع الحظر وعوده
هذه الحسابات مقابل 28% رفضت عوده هذه
الحسابات هذا التصويت هذه النتيجه
ان تزيد من حده الخلاف بين مصر بين هذه
الجمعيات التي تهممه
ان هذه الجماعات ايضا تدعو وتضغط على
المعلنين الكبار من اجل ان يسحب اعلاناتهم
ما يفاقم ازمه التويتر التي تعتمد ب 90 من
الاعلاناتها من مداخلها على هذه الاعلانات
همم ايضا هناك مشاكل عديده يواجهها الى
الماس كما ذكرناها سبق مشاكل تقنيه هو
تحدث في تغريده اخرى على ان ال- ال-
المستخدمين لاحظوا تحسنا بسرعه الانترنت
في العديد او سرعه خدمه التويتر في العديد
من من مناطق حول العالم ولكن بالعوده الى
الى موضوع خطاب الكراهيه هذا موضوع همم هو
ك- كره الثلج في الحقيقه يتبادل الجميع به
همم ان كان من لهم الماسك او من الجمعيات
همم
الناشطون وهذه الجمعيات كانوا قالوا ان
قالوا المسجد استخدم هذا التصويت همم
كحيله للالتفاف على تعهد اعطاه اياهم
سابقا خلال هذا الشارع عندما عقده معه
ويقولون ان هكذا تصويت لا يمكن باي حال من
الاحوال ان يعكس رايه جميع الامريكيين هو
صحيح يشارك به الملايين ولكن هذا غير كافي
هم يقولون ان سياسات الى الماسك جديده
وطموحاطه الى المسكه الجديده ستساهم
بزياده الخطاب الكاميرا رغم انه اشترط بان
اذا همم بالنسبه للحسابات التي ستعود
اشترط ان لا تنتهك الخصوصيه
تبث المعلومات المضله التي تبث خطاب
القرايه هذا شرط بالنسبه له ولكن مع ذلك
هو حتى الان لم يستطع ان يقنعهم كما يبدو
من خلال هذه هذه التوبه التي يتبادلونها
باقل من دقيقه لو سمحت يعني ماذا عن
الحسابات الكبرى المعلنين الكبار الذين
تعتمد عليهم تويتر همم بالتمويل ماذا عنهم
شاهدنا انسحاب اسماء كبيره
من المرجح المشهد انسحابات اخرى خاصه بعد
هذا التصويت اليوم اااه كما قلنا الجمعيات
الحقيقيه تدفع بهذا الاتجاه وترفض كل كل
ما يقوم به الون ماسك يتهمونه بانه يحتال
عليهم ااه لهذا السبب اله الماس الصرح
سابقا بانه يريد ان يبحث عن مصادر اخرى
للتمويل او للوالدات منها الاشتراكات ولكن
امامه همم عقبات كثيره هو ايضا سيواجه ومن
المرجح ان يواجه قريبا متاجر ابل وجوجل
لانها هذه لهذه لهذين قوه وقدره كبيره على
وضع القوانين والزام تويتر همم بها همم
اذا لم يلتزم بالارشادات التي يضعونها
والتي تتعلق ايضا بخطاب الكراهيه وبموضوع
خصوصيه البيانات قد يسحبان التويتر من
متاجرهما ويحرمان كبرى لديه مشكله انه
يدفع لهم همم
غير همم معلنه للحصول على شكرا مراسل
العربيه من سفرنسيسكو
[موسيقى]
بمعجزه نشا الطفل زكى من زلزال اندونيسيا
ما اعطى جرعه امل لاقارب المفقودين وعناصر
الانقاذ واستخدم السلطات الاندونيسيه
الاليات الثقيله والمروحيات والالاف من
العناصر لتحديد مواقع عشرات الاشخاص
العالقين تحت الانقاد بعد ما اودى زلزال
بحياه اكثر من 270 شخصا وتم انتشال بعض
الاحياء من تحت الركام المعدني والاسمنتي
في عمليات انقاذ مؤثره شهداتها بلده سيان
جورى وافاد مسؤولون ان 39 شخصا ما زالوا
في عذاب المفقودين ويتوقع ان ترتفع حصيله
القتل اجراء الزلزال في ظل وجودي
الفيجاريح بينما لا تزال قريتان مقطوعتين
عن العالم
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
المجر المشاكسه للاوروبيين تتحدث بعلم
القديم وترفض الخطه الماليه ضد روسيا
[موسيقى]
لاقر البرلمان الاوروبي دعم الماليه مخصصه
من الاتحاد الاوروبي لاوكرانيا تبلغ
قيمتها 18 مليار يورو في خطه ما زالت
المجر تعرقل تطبيقها واكدت انها تعارض
استدانه التكتل بشكل مشترك لتمويل حزمه
المساعدات وكشفت المجر انها سترسل مساعدات
ماليه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 187 مليون يورو
الخارجيه المجاريه اعلنت ايضا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه قرر اعفاء المجر من تحديد سقف
اسعار النفط الروسيه في المقابل الاثار
رئيس وزراء المجر فيكتور قربان غضب الدول
الجوار من خلال ارتداء وشاحن عليه خريطه
لبلاده تعود الى ما قبل الحرب العالميه
الاولى بما في ذلك اجزاء جرى ضمها الى
النمسا وسوفاكيا ورومانيا وكرواتيا
واوكرانيا وفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
وتعد المجال الاكثر تقاربا مع موسكو من
بين بلدان الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
في حال بقيت شميمه بكم المعروفه بعروس
داعش في سوريا ستشكل خطرا كبيرا على الامن
القومي البريطاني تصريح محير جاء على لسان
رئيس جهاد الاستخبارات البريطاني السابق
ريتشارد باريس الذي سجل رايا مخالفا تماما
لكل التحضيرات السابقه حول عوده الشابه
البالغه من العمر 23 عاما من مخيم الهوى
لعائلات تنظيم داعش في سوريا المدير
السابق لجهازي مكافحه الارهاب العالميه
التابع لجهاز الاستخبارات
البريطاني ام اي 5 وام اي 6 وصفت تقييم
وهو المكتب الخامس في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطاني حول المخاطر الامنيه التي قد
تستعيلها عروس داعش السطحيه وغير الملاءه
وبقائها قال بانه بمخيم داعش يهدد امن
البلاد وحرمانها من جنسيتها كفرد من دون
اي تفسير لكيفيه تحولها من فتاه مراهقه
الى عضو في تنظيم ارهابي هو امر مخيف
المدير السابق لجهازي مكافحه الارهاب
العالمي شدد ايضا على ان بلاده قدمت
استجابه مختلفه عن بقيه الدول لمشكله
اعاده المواطنين الذين سافروا للانضمام
الى داعش مقارنه بالولايات المتحده
والمانيا وفرنس شميمه بيقوم موجوده الان
في مخيم لنازحه عائلات تنظيم داعش في شمال
شرق سوريا
وتحاول شهيده اليوم طلب السماح من بلادها
والعفو عنها واسترداد جنسيتها محامو عروس
داعش في بريطانيا الاسبوع الماضي بقرار
الحكومه البريطانيه لتجريدها من الجنسيه
امام محكمه في لندن اعتبر انها كانت طفله
طفله ضحيه للتهريب لانها كانت في الخامسه
عشر من عمرها عندما غادرت لندن عام 2015
مع اثنتين من رفيقاتها ليتزوجها لاحقا احد
مقاتلي داعش وتنجب منه ثلاثه اطفال توفوا
جميعا وهم في سن الرضاعه وخلال جلسه
الاستئناف كشف محامها ايضا انه تم الاتجار
بها لغرض الاستغلال الجنسي من قبل مقاتل
داعش
[موسيقى]
قلى مطار برلين بر ان برج انه تم استئناف
الرحلات مع بعض التاخيرات اثراء الاضطرار
لاغلاقه مدارج الاقلاع والهبوط بعد قيام
محتاجينه من نشطاء المناخ باقتحام المكانه
وقالت جماعه معنيه بتغير المناخ ان
النشطات نشطاء دعوه الناس الى التوقف عن
السفر
النشره تفكير باب راس العنويه
[موسيقى]
مع نهايه الجوله الاولى من دوري المجموعات
في كاس العالم كبار اسيا يحرجون المرشحين
للفوز بالبطوله
الفاصل بين اوكرانيا وبلاروسيا العربيه
على المثلث الحدودي بين بولندا واوكرانيا
وبيلاروسيا توترا وتعزيزات لحرز الحدود
معلش بس يا اسامه
وانتقد دعم ايران لمليشياتها في المنطقه
فتم اعتقاله انه لاعب الكره الشهير يوري
واقف فوري
المخلب السيفي التركيه تمتد لمناطق بعمق
الشمال السوري للمره الاولى ومساء امريكيه
النشره انتهت لكن اخبار نام مستمره مع
الزميل طاهر و36 ساعه اخباريه جديده مساء
الخير مساء الخير راويه
عن الرهان الروسي على الشتاء هو الذي
تصرفه
بالخسر عن اخر اخبار المونديال والعمليه
التركيه في شمال سوريا والعراق وكذلك عن
فوز السعوديه للمره الاولى كدوله خليجيه
همم رئاسه المجلس التنفيذي لمنظمه السياحه
العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده فارجو ان
تكوني معنا سنه نتحدث الى وزير السياحه
السعوديه ان شاء الله